Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Ah, el amor romántico,
tan hermoso y embriagador,
desgarrador y rompe-corazones,
y a menudo, todo eso al mismo tiempo.
¿Por qué elegimos sufrir
todo ese torbellino emocional?
¿Da el amor sentido a nuestra vida
o se trata de un vía de escape
de nuestra soledad y sufrimiento?
¿Es el amor un disfraz
del deseo sexual,
o un truco biológico
para hacernos procrear?
¿Es todo lo que necesitamos?
¿De hecho, lo necesitamos?
Si el amor romántico tiene un propósito,
ni la ciencia ni la psicología
lo han descubierto todavía.
Pero a lo largo de la historia
algunos de los filósofos más respetados
han propuesto teorías fascinantes.
El amor nos devuelve a la vida.
El antiguo filósofo griego Platón
exploró la idea de que amamos
para sentirnos completos.
En su "Simposio" describe una cena
a la que Aristófanes, un comediógrafo,
entretiene a los huéspedes
con la siguiente historia:
los humanos fueron una vez criaturas
con 4 brazos, 4 piernas y 2 caras.
Un día, enojaron a los dioses,
y Zeus los cortó a todos en dos.
Desde entonces, cada persona
ha estado buscando a su mitad.
El amor es el deseo de encontrar un alma
gemela que nos haga sentir completos
o al menos, es lo que Platón creía que
un cómico borracho diría en una fiesta.
El amor nos engaña para tener bebés.
Mucho, mucho más tarde,
el filósofo alemán Arthur Schopenhauer
mantuvo la idea de que el amor
basado en el deseo sexual
es una ilusión atractiva.
Sugirió que amamos porque
nuestros deseos nos llevan a creer
que la otra persona nos hará felices,
pero estamos muy equivocados.
La naturaleza nos está engañando
para que procreemos
y la unión amorosa que buscamos
cobra vida en nuestros hijos.
Después de satisfacer
nuestros deseos sexuales
volvemos a vivir nuestras
existencias atormentadas,
de forma que solo logramos
mantener nuestra especie
y perpetuar el ciclo
de la monotonía humana.
Aparentemente alguien necesita un abrazo.
El amor es el escape a nuestra soledad.
Según el ganador del Premio Nobel,
el filósofo británico Bertrand Russell,
amamos para saciar nuestros
deseos físicos y psicológicos.
Los seres humanos estamos
diseñados para procrear,
pero sin el éxtasis del amor apasionado,
el sexo no llena.
El miedo hacia este mundo frío y cruel
nos tienta a atrincherarnos
para protegernos y aislarnos.
Los placeres del amor,
la intimidad y la calidez
nos ayudan superar el miedo
que tenemos al mundo,
escapar de nuestros mundos solitarios,
y disfrutar de la alegría de la vida.
El amor nos enriquece
y es lo mejor de la vida.
El amor es una aflicción engañosa.
Siddhartha Gautama,
también conocido como Buda,
o el Iluminado,
probablemente hubiera tenido
discusiones interesantes con Russell.
Buda dijo que amamos porque tratamos de
satisfacer los deseos más elementales.
Sin embargo, estos deseos
apasionados son defectos,
y el cariño, incluso el amor romántico,
son una gran fuente de sufrimiento.
Por suerte, Buda descubrió
el camino de ocho partes,
un tipo de programa
para apaciguar el deseo
para llegar al Nirvana,
un estado elevado de paz, claridad,
lleno de sabiduría y compasión.
El novelista Cao Xueqin
ilustró este sentimiento budista
de que el amor romántico es una locura
en uno de las novelas clásicas de China,
"Sueño en el pabellón rojo".
En una subtrama,
Jia Rui se enamora de Xi Feng
que le engaña y le humilla.
Emociones mezcladas de amor
y odio le rompen el corazón
por lo que un taoísta le da
un espejo mágico que puede curarlo
siempre y cuando no mire
el espejo de frente.
Pero, por supuesto, él mira.
Y ve a Xi Feng.
Su alma queda atrapada en el espejo
y es condenado a morir encadenado.
No todos los budistas piensan lo mismo
acerca del amor romántico y erótico,
pero la moraleja de esta historia
es que esta manera de encariñarse
solo provoca tragedias
y debe, por ende, junto con
los espejos mágicos, evitarse.
El amor nos permite ir
más allá de nosotros mismos.
Acabemos con una nota
ligeramente más positiva.
La filósofa francesa Simone de Beauvoir
propuso que el amor
es el deseo de unirse
y que da sentido a nuestras vidas.
Sin embargo, le preocupaba menos
la razón por la que amamos
y le interesaba más cómo amar mejor.
Vio que el problema
del amor romántico tradicional
es que puede ser tan cautivador,
que queramos hacerlo
nuestra única razón de ser.
Sin embargo, depender del otro
para justificar nuestra existencia
lleva fácilmente al aburrimiento
y a juegos de poder.
Para evitar esta trampa,
Beauvoir aconsejó amar de verdad
algo que se parece más bien
a una gran amistad.
Los amantes se apoyan mutuamente
al descubrirse a sí mismos,
al ir más allá de sí mismos,
y enriquecer sus vidas
y las del mundo juntos.
Aunque puede que nunca sepamos
por qué nos enamoramos,
podemos estar seguros de que conlleva
una montaña rusa emocional.
Es aterrador y estimulante.
Nos hace sufrir
y nos hace volar.
Tal vez perdamos la cabeza.
Tal vez descubramos quienes somos.
Puede que te parta el corazón
o puede que sea lo mejor
que te pasó en la vida.
¿Te atreves a descubrirlo?